Can you see the gut?
Is it hiding the gut?
Do I have breasts?
We need you to make comedy
because life f****** sucks
right now.
I'm going to teach
you about comedy.
How to make it, how to direct
it, how to write it, how to
perform it.
Oh my god, sports?
I love them.
Who are your favorite teams?
The Orlando ... Blooms?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
People should look at comedies
as dramas when they're writing.
They should be stories
that would work just as
well without any jokes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When they're all improvising,
I'll yell out things.
It's almost like I'm a
third actor in the scene.
Oh, that feels warm.
OK, this is going to
hurt a little bit.
That's OK.
[SCREAMING]
Stop smiling.
Ask yourself a lot of questions,
because usually that's where the
humor is, is in your identity.
The more nervous I get,
the more I smile so--
Stop smiling.
Stop it.
You know, you're using
those real-life moments
as ingredients that are
inspired by things that
have happened in your life.
I am you.
And you are me.
And we are making
love to your wife.
And she is us.
And we, we're making
love, you and me.
OK.
People who get
involved in comedy
are upset about something.
I think I spent a
lot of my childhood
alone because people
were playing sports.
I was picked last in gym class.
And it made me angry.
You know what is comedy?
It's speaking your truth
and revealing your darkest,
deepest stuff that for most
people they would keep hidden.
Stories are about
people who are messed up
and need to figure
out a way to grow.
So you want f***** up people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Find the courage to tell
a heartfelt, great story
to show how people try to grow,
how they try to find happiness.
And every once in a while,
they pee with a boner.
I'm Judd Apatow, and
this is my MasterClass.